start and stop alright hang out on air
is live hello there I'm happy to be here
again you know we're all hopefully
engage in our 90-day challenge where
we're working to a breakthrough in our
languages today I want to talk about oh
I have to mute this just a second all
right yeah because I have my iPad going
on the side that's where I can see the
comments and questions so I forgot to
mute it um so much learning is an
exciting thing to do whether you're you
know a teenager in your 20s at a
university students in your professional
life or you know a retired person like
me it's something that is it enriches
our lives at every stage it enriches our
lives because we connect with these
different cultures for example I have my
t-shirt that was given to me the master
and margarita which of course I have
read and listened to in Russian but we
can connect with all these different
things like right now Persian Arabic I'm
getting a sense of those cultures
communities worlds histories that I
never had before all of these things we
get through the language right and I'm
gonna show you a little bit up of how we
do that at link and I'm assuming that
many of you are users of link either on
your mobile devices or on the web as I
said before if you are using one of
those mobile apps for example we always
appreciate a review especially if it's a
favorable review and in the App Store
five stars is a favorable review
anything less than double review so but
today I'm gonna talk a little bit about
struggling to speak because as I have
told you I'm doing sort of half the week
in Persian half the week in Arabic but
this Friday we are having my wife's
birthday party at home we invited a
bunch of neighbors one of the couples is
originally from Iran
I have never ever spoken to them in
Persian and so I kind of want to bring
the level of my Persian up so that I can
have a chat in Persian and Surprise them
so therefore I've spent so much time on
Persian that I've neglected my Arabic
but I do have regularly scheduled
sessions with my tutor Dalia so I still
had to show up for those and of course I
really struggled every time I thought of
something or very often that a Persian
word would pop up and I struggled
mightily so before getting into that I
just wanted you know the phallus for
this thing the fact that I struggle to
speak doesn't bother me it doesn't
detract from my enjoyment of Arabic and
Persian
I do enjoy interacting with my tutor
Dalia and we spoke about a variety of
subjects with difficulty we spoke about
you know the the origins of submitting
languages Aramaic versus Hebrew versus
Arabic which language did the Nabataeans
the people who built Petra which
language do they speak probably Aramaic
um Phoenician Phoenician language the
Phoenicians that's interesting stuff and
I will get back from her a lot of words
that I tried to use and she'll give me a
recording and that would be more content
but the point I'm making is I'm engaging
with Arabic I'm engaging with that world
the fact that I struggle to speak on a
specific occasion doesn't really bother
me and you know again I just want to
point out like we always have to decide
where we spend our time so if I spend
more time acquiring more words and and
kind of raising my level in the language
through extensive listening and reading
then that may not prepare me for a
speaking opportunity and that's where
the many stories are so effective and
there was a discussion on her format
link you know I can't listen to the too
often and they're boring and so on and
so on and I say I listen to the
thirty forty times I don't listen to
them thirty forty times the first time I
listen to them the first time I go
lesson one two three four five back to
one again
listen don't understand read try and
understand a bit more still can't
understand this that whole process yeah
but where I have listened to the first
five ten stories 30 40 50 times it's
because I have gone back to them so many
times eventually go up to ten and 20 and
after less than 20 the many stories have
a variety of tenses not just the present
tense they introduced more sort of
useful connecting words like in my
opinion on the other hand although and
so forth so you're gaining more and more
stuff and yet I still go back to the
first ones to listen to them again
because they train me in the most common
verbs and I find that in order to speak
you need to have good control of the
verbs so if my goal is to do better like
if I'm gonna prepare to have a
conversation with because they're in yin
couple on Friday I'll tend to spend more
time on the mini stories more time on
building up that momentum so that I
could speak better because I'll be
listening to all these verbs and phrases
in my brain and less time acquiring new
words because as you get further and
further into the language the new words
that you acquire you know are lower
frequency they don't repeat that often
and so you're kind of socking them into
your database sucking them into
somewhere in your memory but it's gonna
be a while before they will you know
activate whereas the vocabulary in the
mini stories I can get that to activate
because I'm listening to it so often in
reading and so often it kind of prepares
me for speaking but a lot of the sort of
success we achieve in preparing for
speaking can be quite fragile until we
have done so much listening really that
is really sucked into our memory so we
think we have sort of mastered certain
things and I've had this experience and
if you don't go there for a while like I
leave my Arabic I forgotten it again it
doesn't bother me because forgetting and
then relearning is a very important way
to suck things into your memory so let
me just share my screen briefly I just
wanted to point out a few things and
then I'm gonna go and look at your car
questions see share screen and this one
here and so now just want to share with
you so this is uh this is in immersion
and farsi person i my tutor is rana
she's an excellent tutor i haven't yet
used i'm house
i may try to i don't know it may be that
the times didn't work for me
he certainly less expensive than rana
but Rama is an excellent tutor and I get
so much value from each lesson because I
get a detailed report I get the audio
and I use that as learning material so I
might hear the harm hostage try again I
just don't remember why I didn't go with
a must and you will see in my activities
as it loads that I have actually bought
a whole bunch of lessons ahead of time
so I've received these conversation
reports in Farsi and Persian and Arabic
and here I have not yet received my
report from I'm sorry every 28 that's
tomorrow so tomorrow I will have my
conversation in person and then I want
to really get back to my Arabic because
I feel I disappointed Dalia because I
didn't do so well and kept throwing out
Persian words so if this week has been
heavy to Persian starting Saturday I'm
gonna go very heavy to Arabic and
hopefully I will do better in my
conversation with Dalia but the point is
even if even if I struggle to speak to
me it's not such a big deal a lot of
people are very concerned
how'd they do in in speaking I mean
eventually I look at it as a long-term
thing eventually if I consume all the
different variety of things that I have
here I will eventually you know learn to
speak I know because I've done it in
other languages and I just want to have
a look at French which is not a language
that I am learning first thing I just
want to remind you all again there are
settings that link so you can decide
whether you want them to default to my
lessons default to the library you know
the fault here well calculator and you
can default to wherever you want sort of
library I tend to default to my lessons
you can you know choose to have the
guide of course not have the guy to the
cards demo class your interface language
some people like to have their interface
language in a third language of the
language they're learning you can you
know in the feed which is where the
content comes out to you can just follow
your friends and so forth similarly with
the reader you can control the text size
very important for Arabic because all
the books that I find for learning
Arabic have super small font which is
extremely annoying so at least here I
can control the font size I can also
control the you know the text-to-speech
now some people criticize text-to-speech
it's not accurate is this and that I
find it very useful it's just we
shouldn't expect perfection so you can
choose who you want and you can also
move all words to known when you to move
the page or choose not to do so so I
think it's a good idea to experiment
with these different ways of working
your lesson page and you can also look
at one sentence at a time too and so for
you can control what you see on the
screen so similarly with review what you
see on your flashcards you can can
control it if you want to you know
however many cars per session if you
want to see multiple choice or not
dictation which in some ways is the most
difficult so I just want to remind you
that you do have settings
and and so getting back then to this
this idea that that exploring the
language to me is the biggest sort of
attraction I feel that the ability to
speak will come so I am now with the
Persian and Arabic speaking much much
earlier than I ever did before and I
attribute that to the many stories but I
know that that and part of it is that I
haven't found in Persian and Arabic the
range of content that's available in
other languages so I tend to stay with
what I have but the more time and effort
and bother we put into how well we're
gonna speak now that's time we take away
from building up our long-term
capability in the language now if in a
language like France where we have a lot
of material you know the range of stuff
that you know there's something from
from my book too from my book there's
literature there's all kinds of stuff
and this is the lesson to feed this is
what other people are study I can look
at you know the most popular lessons I
can browse the library you know I can
look at books so I mean there's such a
range of things that we can study from
and explore and explore through the
language and then exploring through the
language we are part of the language and
then we can go and talk so how well or
poorly I do in my conversations today
doesn't bother bother me I know that
it's um whether it be Persian or Arabic
it's a long-term project and I will
eventually get that there so now I'm
going to stop the screen sharing and
stop oh
okay now now let me look at questions
all right so we're gonna whip to the top
here so what's good blah blah blah the
Russian underground shirt hi from Brazil
hi hey Steve if you don't use much
English with your tutors what strategies
do you use to communicate can't find
words to say what you want to say I use
English okay if I really struggle and I
must say that my tutors are very good
they don't give in that easily even if I
speak to them in English they'll try and
rephrase it in Arabic or Persian but
yeah if I can't get my meaning across I
have to use English hi guys
Kazakhstan Wow and Canada is its name
yeah yeah okay hello Aaron is Esther
yeah hello friends can llaman learn
english last--which Steve yeah we use
xclusive all do
picanha will you ever not easily would
you even notice oh yeah so the question
is can I learn nope I was just listening
without sort of memorizing it if I
understand that correctly
yeah the listening is picking up a
little bit at a time settlements are
settling in your brain I have never been
a fan of trying to master anything
memorize anything I simply don't like
doing it it may be that it's effective
but I just don't like doing it so no
I've met Mohamed for every sort of
committee meeting I'm at salamat C's Bay
whatever that is merhaba okay how do you
develop an energy of not being bothered
by speaking mistake so I always feel
embarrassed you know I'm happy to learn
my language
I would rather not make mistakes but I'm
communicating to the extent that I
communicate I'm happy I'm I'm
disappointed that I can't do better
but I'm happy it's better there than not
communicating how do you say languages
to a short time languages take time so
the less time you have the less well
you're gonna do onion SEO okay okay
I'll let you tour a and my cuz that's
what you sleep at the ocean effective no
no yeah do me oh yes miss Lee zoom
breach and Macedo noisy which means
matter procrastinate how do you not how
do you how you don't forget the
languages you don't have much contact
with they slide they slide but when
you're first of all my top ten languages
it not to forget the others I definitely
slide but if I get back into them I very
quickly return to the level I had before
and there's all kinds of research that
shows that the brain forgetting
relearning for getting leaner relearning
is in fact an important part of the
learning process what language have you
enjoyed the most and why I enjoy them
all now I enjoy them all like right now
when I like Farsi is a lot easier than
Arabic so I enjoy the fact that I Arabic
at the far far as your Persian is easier
but I'm very much looking forward to
getting back into my Arabic they're all
enjoyable in their own ways I can't I
can't select one how does one learn that
more colloquial language that literature
doesn't provide for example what you
hear in movies here on the street ok I
have never worried too much about slang
I don't come across it that often
I think it's something that we pick up
naturally I focus on learning whatever
content you know I'm using that's what I
learned from if they're slang in there
I'll pick that up if I want to do more
slang I'll find myself more slang
e-content to listen to and read what you
listen to and read is gonna dictate what
you learn and how you speak but I would
caution you on using slang and even more
so any bad language
we always think it's fun to use slang or
even
language and alert in a language we're
just learning we don't necessarily know
how those words are used and sometimes
it can create a bad impression we're
better off in my opinion to stay with
neutral language until we can just
naturally use the slang or even foul
language because we know how it's used
so I think people are too quick to jump
into slang and even swear words como vai
Vita muy bonito bank' no main result of
habla it's a problem I finished most
people learn the standard language and
don't really learn the colloquial age
fine Finnish people operate don't favor
the standard rent talk amongst
themselves yeah I mean this is an issue
in Persian where the written language is
I would say significantly different in
many ways from the spoken language but
as long as you get content like these
things can you can have it written
either the way it's spoken or written in
the standard form but if you listen say
over and over to the spoken language
that's what you're gonna get used to you
think that having read more than a
million words and link in Spanish with
$35,000 words is enough to read physical
books in Spanish with very minor
problems yes at that level you can but
you know even languages where I have 50
65 thousand words like check whatever if
I have a large article to read I will
bring it into link just so that I can if
there's five percent 3 percent 5 percent
7 percent unknown words I can add them
to my database and have a chance of
sitting in them again so but yeah I can
read I can read check I can read polish
without the dictionary I just miss a few
things but I always feel it's a pity
that I'm missing these words and I know
from experience that it's too much
effort to look them up in a traditional
dictionary however if I can bring them
out like chronically into link and
that's what I prefer to do I think
learning language is one of the best
ways to engage with the culture
absolutely it's fun it's it's the way to
go - American living in Germany hi
Nabataean in Petra hiya spoke ancient
North Arabian Aramaic
okay you know when I spoke with my tutor
she assumed that they had spoken Aramaic
and I know by the way this is - Ahmad Al
Harb ii/iii
as I started getting interested in
Arabic and stuff and I do fall will
start to follow certain people on
Twitter I know that there's some
discussion now that you know I had
assumed that the Arabic language came
from you know Saudi Arabia and in fact
there seems to be increasing discussion
that the arabian the arabic language
originated is somewhere in this is sort
of the southern part of sort of
palestine in that little area there so
and that would be precisely you know
jordan where the Nabataeans were so i am
by no means an expert but i do i do
enjoy getting involved and learning and
even if again like I'm not a
perfectionist so I take up some stuff
some is a truce and it's not who the
exploration is fun you know if we're
exploring a forest and we make the odd
wrong turn it's still fun which
statistics are linked you feel is most
representative of your progress links
known words words read etc to me known
words known words and bear in mind that
all of these statistics are
approximations they reflect a level of
activity more than anything else but I
mean linking drives it you need to
create a lot of links that means that
you're looking upwards but ultimately
you want to be reading a lot and adding
to your known word total most of what
you add to your known word total
eventually is going to be words that you
didn't ever look up because you have
learned so many other words that are
related to those words that pretty soon
you don't need to look up so many words
they're just being moved to known
naturally and I always look about look
at the known word toward which you know
has a different value depending on the
language that's kind of the best measure
of your potential in the language now
getting back to today's subject of
struggling to speak you may still
struggle to speak but you have a base
you have a potential to to really
develop your speaking capability
you have a lot of words because you're
gonna be able to understand what people
are saying
that's hideously tippin you might 60% of
the text so if you only understand 60%
of the text how do you read the book I
read on length I read with online
dictionaries 60% is not enough I think
that if you're reading on a book without
the use of online dictionaries or link
you need 90 95 % vocabulary
okay all right missed one here I can
read a little bit and translate from
English to Portuguese but I cannot speak
yeah you can write well enough in
English I'm sure you can speak you just
have to speak more and not worry about
it the only way to become a good speaker
of a language is to speak a lot
eventually but I feel it's important to
to not just speak but to build up a base
build up the vocabulary build up the
comprehension give you yourself some
weapons some tools so that you're in a
position then to progress with oh thank
you yeah no Slavs zubich is learned by
heart oh good see now Russian is kind of
my I would say 9th or 10th lame it's
that on the on the cusp between
languages that I feel that I speak well
and languages where I struggle for the
simple reason that item haven't spoken
much Russian you know German I've
traveled on the Autobahn when I was
doing business there hours and hours
stuck in traffic speaking German
speaking I've spoken lots of Swedish
just spoken lots of French I've spoken
these other languages more and but the
fact that I don't know certain words
like zubich I have a large vocabulary in
Russian I can listen to podcasts on
history and politics so I understand
them god bless I read you know post I
stuff and maybe some where I came across
the word zoo bridge learn by heart
but I don't know what it means and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter you
know however even if it's French or a
language that I claim to speak well and
someone points out that I made a mistake
or I didn't use the wrong word or I
forgot it doesn't bother me which
language is more easy to learn well
it's a pretty general question but if I
use an example if I'm there
Persian to Arabic Persian is a lot
easier because it's an indo-european
language the structure is similar to
European languages there are some
loanwords from French or English not so
many far more loanwords from Arabic but
the structure is is similar and the
writing system is easier for some reason
it's more consistent whereas Arabic
because the structure is so different
and the writing system is a little more
difficult to decipher and if you're a
Spanish speaker or a Portuguese speaker
obviously Spanish is gonna be easy for
you and Russian will not be so it
depends what your background is you know
when the person right right I understand
then she speaks the same scent inside
down and I do not understand okay then
you need to do a lot more listening you
have to train the brain it just takes
time and when you're listening and you
don't understand read the text and then
listen again and you gradually gradually
the brain will learn the brain is a
learning machine the brain learns based
on stimulus experience but you have to
feed it enough stimulus and experience
and the brain learns slowly the brain
doesn't learn quickly but the brain
cannot do otherwise than learn it's
designed to learn all right Venetian
aigu come under strongly result yes but
also known as always no big deal but
also in Victor Berto you miss me oh yeah
I mean when I read if I'm reading on
Lake I look up every word I don't know
because it goes into my database I can
review them a blue word book is now
yellow I'll come across it again if I'm
reading a book away from the computer
and I prefer to do that only when I have
at least 90 percent of the vocabulary
then I don't look anything up I don't
like anything out because I've found
from experience that I forget it very
very quickly after looking it up so I
don't there's nothing gained there that
whereas as if I learn if I read them
linked and all of those words even
though I forget them I see the next time
in yellow I'm reminded I've seen the
word before it's stuck there both in my
physical database are linked and in my
cerebral database
so that's for how I prefer to do them
Lima Ramona my intelligent don't you
have much in writing I studied only
Anisha limba Roman I forgotten a lot but
it's a language speaking of a easy to
learn Romanian is easy to learn if you
know Italian if you know some Slavic
languages Romanian is easy to learn
great country divisive unfortunately you
know I prepared for my trip there and
then I haven't had much occasion to do
anything in rent Romanian but it's there
I haven't lost it and if I were to go
back to Romanian within a few days I
would be back where I was and then I
would be progressing beyond that with a
more solid base than ever because when
we forget and relearn that base is more
solid than it ever was
do you have a question wait a sec if we
choose to learn more than one language
at the same time should it be different
languages such as French and Japanese
are closed languages such as Spanish and
Italian I admit I don't know like
Persian and Arabic are different
language systems they share some common
vocabulary it helps when I come across
Arabic origin words in Persian but I
think if a person you'd have to go and
do it I mean we can experiment try
learning similar languages try learning
different languages see what works I do
believe we have the capability of
learning a lot of languages I'm much
more convinced of that now than I was
before and before I was fairly sort of
convinced that you had to focus on one
that you needed a high level of
intensity this was my experience in
learning Chinese but no I'm doing Arabic
and Persian and I feel I'm progressing
in both the brain is switching back and
forth I think the sort of novelty factor
is good for the brain I think we should
experiment I think people can all learn
three or four or five languages and do
some of them at the same time ah boy
lava hey boy lava
there's Greek there's another one that I
want to get back to I'm from Brazil I
have difficulty speak let's speak more
then speak more Naruto hi okay say I
said
versus Guevara cult que la Luna he must
know Sarah Khouri complicity so all the
action there are good schools key
follicle una a c1 c2 muscle una nonsense
pressico very positive so in my opinion
when we're talking c1 c2 we're talking
about all of the language skills now
it's possible for someone to have to be
very advanced in reading and and not so
advanced in speaking or vice-versa and I
think even that the b2 level I guess my
my sense is that when you say you're
beat till you say you're fluent that
means you can speak and in order to be
able to speak fluently you have to have
a large vocabulary therefore you can
read if you are c1 c2 you have to be
very good in all the skills like super
good native level high native speaker
level it's not possible that someone
could be c1 and c2 in reading and not
not you know able to speak if I
understood the question correctly can we
learn a language by watching video okay
to me video is a reward I like them
my wife's been watching is Turkish
serial on Netflix soap opera it makes me
want to learn Turkish but I have never
learned from watching videos because
it's too time-consuming you know I can
listen while doing other stuff I can sit
down and read but if I have to sit down
to learn to actually watch a video the
whole time it's totally occupies me and
typically the videos movies are less
sort of word dense then when we're
listening we just rely on the words when
we read we just rely on the words and
when we're watching video we have all
this action and people are jumping
around and stuff but of course it's
whenever we enjoy doing
if and I very I would like if I were to
go into Turkish I would definitely watch
those series and we can now go to UQ
using that link extension I can bring
videos in and the subtitles are text to
be studied at link I can listen to the
audio and take it away so if I work the
video that way with text with audio and
then I mentioned I get better and better
at understanding the movie to that
extent I think it's really good
otherwise if we don't have a good level
in the language I think movies really
don't move us along that far that's been
my experience but it's what people enjoy
doing can we learn neither okay where to
look for native speakers to practice
with hey which language B there's all
kinds of sites that offer language
exchange or tutors including link and
you can sign up with one of our tutors
oh yeah I'm learning is to listening on
t video but I still feel that I'm not
getting perfect you probably won't get
perfect we have to be realistic you will
continue making mistakes I make mistakes
and all the languages that I speak but I
can continue to improve and I can
continue enjoying it so if you are
watching videos let's say in English I
hope you're enjoying the videos so if
you're enjoying it that's mission
accomplished number one in the language
learning the process is the goal we want
to enjoy the process of learning a
language and if we do that we will
improve but we probably won't achieve
perfection okay I keep on getting
presses a PewDiePie not interested do
you think that there are hacks or trick
to activate your passive kaveri without
speaking or is there no way around it
that's okay I mean hacks you can start
by writing if you have the patience to
do so because with writing you have the
time to look words up to look up you
know conjugation tables or whatever it
might be to make sure that your writing
is somewhat accurate but it's a lot
easier just to speak so I mean why would
you invent
a hack to do something when the easiest
thing to do is to just about speaking
and not worry about how you struggle and
then I think nowadays even if you aren't
surrounded by speakers of the language
even to have three sessions a week with
the tutor online it's gonna help you
more you know activate your language and
particularly the way the way I do it at
link is I get a report back so I I read
the words that I struggle to use I
listen to them pronounced and read by my
tutor I listen to that three four five
times probably make the same mistake
again but gradually I get better at
speaking so you just have to put in the
time I'm not aware a hack I think that
many stories are a bit of a hack for
getting to speaking because they focus
on the most common verbs and there's so
much repetition that you can kind of
tricking the brain to start using those
common expressions and common verbs so
that would be the only sort of hacker
trick that I could think of is it okay
to understand other language in our
language I mean I think it's just back
to this whole point of you know
translating into our own language we
continue to do it for a long long time
nothing wrong with it because whatever
we're learning it has to refer to
something that we already know and so we
are right from the beginning you know if
it's libro it's book okay it has to
relate back to something that we know
and so we continue doing that but slowly
we start to identify meaning just based
on the language itself but it's it's a
gradual process I don't get drama one of
them do you agree that the reaction of
your interlocutor when speaking has a
large inference yes thank you
slat is happy white we are gonna speak
better with some people than with other
people I believe that there's this whole
even in terms of content like we want to
listen to content that we light where we
like the voice we want to talk to people
who make us feel comfortable and because
anytime that there's pressure or
negative emotions we do less well that's
why the tutors I think tutors who make
me feel comfortable who are able to ask
questions that get me talking who are
encouraging where there's a good Skype
connection or you know person-to-person
there are some people that make you
nervous and you don't speak well and
other people that put you at ease and
you speak well so definitely hey guys
when it comes to be I'm at a good level
but I want to learn to talk about more
topics well to learn to talk about more
topics you have to have more words and
the higher degree of comprehension and
that's the whole point you have to
continue so there's you can you know
work on speaking better but you also
have to invest in developing your
comprehension and your vocabulary level
so that eventually you are then adding
first to your passive vocabulary but
then eventually those if you be your
engaging conversations on those subjects
and you hear them coming at you from
your the person you're speaking to
slowly in those words and expressions
will activate for you but it starts with
it starts with reading more broadly okay
but Todd how long does it take to get
intermediate in Chinese since you have
about one hour it is one hour a day to
get to intermediate I mean it's gonna be
two hour two years but it's it's a long
time because because the characters the
characters are a lot of work and you
can't be intermediate and first of all
let's define intermediate so in the
European you know framework of reference
they have a 1 & 2 which is beginner B 1
& 2 which is intermediate and C 1 and 2
which is advanced no true intermediate
is closer to be 2 than 2 B 1 B 1 is is
not so difficult to get to B 2 which is
what I call fluency fluency with
mistakes fluency with gaps fluency on a
wide range of subjects that takes a long
time so if let's say that I when I
studied Chinese in say 10 months 6 hours
a day
let's say 300 days just to pick an easy
number 300 days six hours a day how much
is uh 1800 hours right so if you're
gonna go an hour a day
it's gonna be a long time so now I was
fairly fluent so oh yeah you need lots
of hours two years three years okay how
are in your experience is it possibly
fluid in speaking from input alone no no
the input is preparing you creating the
potential for you to become fluent
fluent means fluent it flows you can
speak you can speak on a variety of a
variety of subjects even as you make
mistakes and to do that you have to
speak a lot the languages that I speak
the best are the languages that I have
spoken the most can you recommend some
resources for beginners in Russia well I
think that the content that we have at
link is phenomenal you have everything
you need there
I typically what I do though is like for
Persian here I've started with our mini
stories I did a lot of work in link and
by the way our resources for Russian I
blame our far far greater than what we
have in Persian but I also bought a book
because if we can study the same
material in different ways in a book and
laying different courses at Lane even
different books I bought both color
ochio and living language both have the
same fault that there's so much English
on their audio I don't have the patience
to win go in there and remove the audio
but it is additional content beginner
content and so you go and look for what
you want there's lots of stuff online by
a book but I definitely would recommend
getting into the Russian content at link
means to memorize - okay thank you I
want to study Russia
under my rush there's awful
recommendations just like the previous
person get on link we got lots of stuff
in Guinea in st. Petersburg for example
is created tremendous content we got
content at every level from beginner to
advanced grammar explanations do you
name it all with audio and text there is
no better place to study Russian than
link but we need the other DVD on the
Reznick is if you're interested we look
for solutions I have done so in the past
I will do so in the future I've done
videos in in French and Japanese and
Chinese and Russian and German and
Italian you just have to look at my
YouTube channel and you'll find them
treats from Germany love your videos
thank you it's good like do you think
that your brain would learn easier if
you were 20 years younger
no I feel that I'm like I have never
learned my languages as quickly as not
even in Persian and Arabic and in Greek
I started speaking earlier than ever
before I was like six eight months in
check before I dared speak Russian I
waited I can't remember a year or more
longer before I started speaking I saw
and part of it is link is better than it
was
I believe the many stories take you to
speaking earlier I'm a more confident
learner I just know I can do it we can
present necessarily the case 20 years
ago so I have no evidence that I would
have learned faster 20 years ago but
it's possible I just simply don't know
you don't need Slavic languages to
underwrote understand Romanian you need
Italian Spanish event yeah you don't
need anything but 20 percent of the
words in a number of the words like I
think you pretty appropriate all I think
is is friend I can't remember but there
are 20 percent Slovak words in Romanian
that's just a fact
but 75 percent are you know similar to
Italian unlink how many known words
corresponds to see one level in your
best estimation for a Romance language
now bear in mind the
picking in order to consider yourself c1
but and I haven't done the numbers but I
think you're getting up to 50,000 words
but I thought I can understand English
but when it comes to speaking I forget
lots of words everybody is like that
that's not unique you have to keep on
speaking I am studying French so hard
but I really get to speak with someone
what tell you about this situation
well I mean there are online there are
online places where you can find
languages changes you know look for the
opportunity and be happy when you find
it but in the meantime continue with
what you can do which is preparing you
for speech so do a lot of listening and
reading yeah I mean it's a problem try
to find people to talk to it's it's a
problem I have Google here you know
person speakers in Palm Springs Arabic
speakers in the end I I end up talking
online with my tutors I get a report
back I'm building my capability one day
I might have the opportunity to you know
use it more what about the future or her
chest
ciske what about the future plane what
about package for schools we have a
program for schools we have some
teachers using link we'd be happy to
talk to any teacher about setting up
sort of like an of a limited environment
for schools to use link in the classroom
we would like to do more of that
I think link is is ideal for a classroom
environment I believe kids in school
could learn more than one language and I
believe the focus should be on
comprehension and if they achieve some
success in comprehension they will be
motivated to learn to speak better not
just one but several languages come on
Oh fine I will have the opportunity to
study in Spain a suite and I would like
to know which is easier to learn which
is easier to learn to get there and
understanding the lessons and get a good
speaking um you know it entirely depends
on your I don't think there's much
difference actually I think both are
what
I would consider it relatively easy
languages for English speakers to burn
can you suggest some resources for the
Russian language content for beginner
and again please go and have a look at
what we have at link and if you don't
want to join link that's fine too e you
can download the content it's all
available free of charge audio and text
go and have a good look and if that's
not enough you can also ask on our forum
at link it's good gig city suggest is a
good night Steve well very roughly 10
that I can sort of turn on and another 7
and 8 or 8 that I would have to work on
now I'm trying to add two more which is
Arabic and Persian okay how to make the
most describe glasses if you want to
develop your speaking skills
well again you have to build up the
potential to speak well and so what I do
is I have natural conversations with my
tutor
at a very early stage where I'm having
all kinds of trouble reading especially
the Arabic script then I was reading
with my tutor I may do a little more of
that but the big thing in the
disadvantage of reading with my tutor is
then I'm not learning any new words so
if we have a natural conversation then I
get back a rapport with an audio you
know four or five six minutes long so
I'm learning more words and that's how I
get the most out of it talked earlier
about the importance of having a to do
that you like who keeps you talking
where you feel comfortable and you just
keep doing it and keep up with your
activities and eventually you get better
hello in your Japanese learning
experience what do you think about jlpt
having a clue what Japanese books know
business books would you recommend for
intermediate advanced parts okay I have
never done any tests in Japanese as for
books and stuff again I think you just
have to Google I'm not studying Japanese
right now we have some content that link
I like you know what I did with say
polish and others is I found online
publishers I bought audio mix books for
which I could find the corresponding
eBook and then I imported the e-book
into the link I didn't bother with the
sound I kept that on iTunes
and that's how I learned so if you can
find audio material for which you can
also get the e-text then I would listen
to that audio and I would bring the
e-text into link but when I was studying
abroad link your prostitute convinced me
to drop the grammar books and pick up
and Falls good now you can totally drop
the grammar books but grammar is there
for reference when you are curious about
something when you already have some
exposure experience in the language then
the grammar X places makes sense and
they stick but when the grammar box
tried to teach you grammar upfront
before you have any sense of the
language I think that's very low
effectivity low efficiency type of you
know learning activity okay so thank you
okay hey man how's your Arabic going
okay Abdi Arabic as I kind of sort of
struggle a bit right now because I've
been so heavy to Persian in preparation
for my the party were having a Friday
I'm going to make a video in Arabic and
either I'll speak myself or I'll get on
chat with someone although the Skype
chest is the sound and the picture
quality sometimes very poor you will so
see but I'm enjoying it what helped you
to understand Chinese cultural better so
it's that meaningful conversations with
the speak language any recommended so
resources again you know it's been so
long see what we have a link I use the
Yale in China series and they have
published so I would Google Yale in
China Chinese there's lots of material
there that's what I use so I just
suggest you you google it and see what
you can find
would you consider having listen for 200
total hours over six months to be a very
active or just normal so that's say 30
hours a month that's an hour a day
that's quite active I mean ah that's
good that's good it's not super active
but but it's good cartoons I don't use
but if that's what you like fine you are
comes a story thank you so much I think
is the best thing
you do you think that the increase in
brain plasticity that comes from
language like you can carry over to
other mental skills such as play music
or man I have no idea I have no idea but
I think any time we are using our brains
to learn something new that's a good
thing and we are creating new neurons
and whether that be playing music or
math or learning though you know play
the violin it's all good stuff something
here in Turkish one day I will
understand how many languages can you
maintain a fluid level and I have no
idea but you know I spent most of my
life as a businessman and recently have
become involved in more language
learning but I still have only an hour
and a half or so a day to spend at it
you know oh I would play golf we have
friends we do all kinds of other stuff I
don't know there was a man in Vancouver
who was a court interpreter in 40
languages so I think the number is
actually quite high I think you take the
leading poly glass like Luke the lamp or
you Laura
Richard simcha and others there up in
the 20s yeah yeah the Serge says three
out to a buddy but I'm saying in
Romanian if I remember correctly there's
a similar word but I don't trust me on
that
I really like these persons that much
how much longer how off will you do
these nights again I don't know we'll
see but we're doing them now for the 90
day challenge when should we start
reading a novel in the target language
as soon as you feel up to it and it's a
big move I've often said you know that
first novel you read it's like climbing
a mountain that that changes your
perception of the language your
perception of yourself as to learner of
that language and depends on the
language depends on you know obviously
is gonna be faster in Spanish say where
a lot of the words are similar to
English and where the writing system is
the same it's gonna be it's come take
longer in Chinese or Arabic between
Russian and Chinese which language took
you the longer time to get to it okay
well I'm more fluent in Chinese than I
am in Russian but Chinese was a fault
six seven hours a day occupation Russian
was an hour a day an hour and a half a
day so the Chinese was ten months and
the Russian was years but that's it's
more a function of hours than than years
how does link compared to other courses
price-wise I have no idea
ours is $10 a month for 33 languages how
do you think I say thank you because I
could not grade my love all the
languages that you think great to hear
that why do people keep saying it's all
Greek to me
we're not understanding something I mean
there are more difficult language okay
look it up etymology you'll find it
might have come from Roman times it's
like with a grain of salt comes from
Latin so we don't know when these
expressions some things a lot of things
came from Shakespeare we don't know
where these expression me we do
something we'll know I don't know is it
very is it worth recording when you're
trying to improve your speaking it can
be I did it when I was learning Chinese
and French to some extent I don't do it
now you know you have to experiment with
these things it's not very I think would
be a good thing to do especially you
sort of listen to a paragraph and then
try and repeat that paragraph with the
same intonation at the same speed even
if you get the odd word wrong and then
listen to it work on your intonation
that way it can be a very useful thing
to do I just don't do it right now to
make in 15 or our language is a high
level like fluent or would you go crazy
no I think that's possible is it worth
to her okay do you recommend speaking to
yourself okay I don't do it but people
like doing it that's you know the thing
about language learning is we can
explore and experiment with things and
see if a if it useful and B there are
things that are useful to do that we
just can't force herself to keep doing
so you know for example translating or
writing or all good things to do we may
or may not want to put the time or we
don't have the patience necessarily to
do them okay
do you recognize speaking Czech Joe
thanks so much for the Japanese advice
you know I have a normal almost fluent
yeah I would say posted
it's kind of more or less get along in
there I can do more but then I'd have to
warm up a bit I'm not about to learn I
don't think I would be learning mayor I
have to be realistic there's thousands
of languages out there a Turkish
possibly Hindi is is where I'm headed
next I think she she okay her question
and polish does the speed new languages
diminish with age not in my case I'm
learning faster now than ever so I don't
think so I'm right here
I couldn't listen right you need to know
I can comprehend your speech for example
but keeps throwing it with some fast
speech is that okay yeah it's all okay
as long as we're improving and we should
not measure ourselves against some
perfection model it doesn't exist
come on Sava good can we learn language
through listening scary stories any
novel that you're interested in if
you're interested in the subject matter
is gonna help you should I work on those
five to perfect them okay if you have
five languages should I you know I
constantly struggle with this I could go
back and improve in every one of the
languages that I speak
should I do that or should I learn a new
language depends what you want to do
right now I'm enjoying exploring Persian
and Arabic do you feel fiction or
nonfiction is better for learning
nonfiction to me is much easier because
fiction has a lot more sort of column
low frequency words and nonfiction were
often familiar with the context if we
are familiar with the context it's
easier to learn so I like nonfiction I
find it it's a great sort of
intermediate stepping stone towards say
literature how do you review when
reading listening to novels I get bored
okay if I'm at the novel stage I'm not
rereading the rereading read listening
is strictly with the sort of mini
stories that are starting to get me
going once I'm at a high intermediate
level I'm only listening once I'm only
reading once okay do you recommend
watching
with outside ones then watching you know
I don't recommend watching stuff that
you don't understand so if you're
watching with subtitles it's because
you're enjoying it I don't think you're
improving your language that much I said
more than any other but I find that
struggled more than then with everything
besides accent thoughts you know it
depends what you're what you're doing to
study if you're pouring over grammar
rules you aren't making much progress as
if you are engaging with interesting
content lots of listening and reading I
think you'll find that you'll progress
more quickly
ich kann zero Deutsch listen don't
forget easier of the birth of any site -
esperen order to ship its tips okay
yeah I mean we all struggle with that we
all struggle with that but just it's
just you have to keep doing it he says
you know I always you know I can read
but then I remember words when I was
speaking everyone does that everyone
does that words that even that I've been
reviewing in my mini stories and I
really think I mastered when I go to
speak bingo I can't I can't find that
word even a word that I know I can't
find let alone words that I haven't a
chance of remember so that's perfectly
normal
you just have to keep on going I do a
must know one guy this Condit you off
well you ever consider learning Hebrew I
went out Hebrew briefly about it before
I visited Israel I definitely want to
get back but right now I'm focused on
burgers in an Arabic then perhaps
Turkish and I may very well go back to
Hebrew okay yeah it's difficult not to
have people to speak to how do you
handle reading novels but I can't bring
myself to reread okay so come go I say
oh yeah come go again one of your
pricing alignment but the native keepers
native keeps stretching the English also
have you been a situation [ __ ] a group
of natives and it's harder than one what
two questions first of all yeah
depending on where you are
you know I found this in Portugal the
first time I learned Portuguese everyone
switched English this can happen in
Germany it can happen
I don't have learned Dutch but places
where the English level is high I mean
if you're talking to someone their goal
is to communicate with you they're not
your language teacher and they want to
get meaning across so if they feel that
your language is not good enough they'll
switch to English it could be a number
of reasons a because they don't have the
patience to humor you in the language
you're learning bTW because they want to
show off their English see then they
think that they make you feel more
comfortable that this particular English
any number of reasons so the only
solution there is not everyone is gonna
be that way find people who are happy to
speak to you in the language that you're
learning and continue improving your
language until or and of course if they
come back to you in English you just go
back to you to them in the language
you're learning that's what I do then
usually don't give in and speak to me in
the language that I want to speak to but
I mean they have the right to want to
speak in English so you don't have the
right to impose on them the language is
it your learning and then the second
question was yeah group is harder than
one-on-one no question if you have
one-on-one with a sympathetic native
speaker you're gonna do a lot better if
you're in a group sometimes you don't
understand what they're saying to each
other and B when you choose to jump in
you somehow feel now boy I better you
know say what I have quickly and maybe
no one will understand me and there but
they interrupt me and so the whole scene
is much more stressful so of course you
do better one-on-one and a high ste this
is my first time catching I glad you're
participate okay thanks you're great
it's pretty how far we're length until
take me given I followed the learning
process that link system will take you
as far as you want because the material
in our libraries will only take you
whatever so far soon you'll be done with
them you there's nothing of interest
there for you anymore and that's what
I've done and then I Google I search I
find online publishers of that language
I find audiobooks with corresponding
ebooks like polish audio technica for
example in Polish and Czech there's I
remember a leafless or something for
Russian there's all kinds of stuff out
there and then I just import that in the
link so link is building up your
potential but then
eventually I'll start speaking and you
speak with our tutors or find other
people to speak to but the bulk of the
effort remains building up your
capability your potential in the
language how far we like the time does
watching content your target language
with silence and your target language
hurt you're listening no it doesn't know
I'm not 77 I'm 73 uh you know I suppose
subarashii she uh she talked Elam was
good she okay it says do you who's
reading to learn a language since the
beginning or is it better to have a good
level on the language to read well I
read at Lane so I begin by reading I
begin by reading and listening I begin
by reading and listening getting sense
of the language
okay he's no reference to some grammar
issues which I forget and that's how I
learned what do you think about learning
to learn is the same time while I learn
Russian because I want Korean my
mother's family is rustled by the way
too I'm doing it right now
give it a try aye-aye come on now three
days on Persian three days on Arabic you
can go one month on one language one
month on another I said yeah I don't
want to do that because if I leave the
well language for a month it might be
more difficult to get back into it I
think it's fine okay thank you Denise
says I inspired you that's good and I've
screen fits you very well keep it up I
want to beat achieve okay which language
do you think simple to learn no language
is simple to learn okay and I think if
that where we've got an hour here yeah
all languages the question is which
languages are fun to learn and they're
all fun to learn alright thank you for
participating bye for now